When I grow up, I want to be a meteorologist.
When I grow up, I want to be a police officer.
I want to be a firefighter when I grow up.
Because they fight fires.
When I grow up, I want to be a teacher.
And I want to be a nurse.
When I grow up, I want to be a paleontologist.
When I grow up, I want to be a princess.
When I grow up, I want to be a basketball player.
When I grow up, I want to be a doctor for pets.
When I grow up, I want to be a police officer.
I want to be a basketball player and if not, I'll be a paleontologist.
I want to be a ballerina and I want to be a gymnastic girl...
...and I want to be an animal doctor and a doctor.
I would like to be a veterinarian.
I want to be a princess when I grow up.
I want to be Batman.